the entire game brooklyn came back from  21 down to tie it  there's mike james operating james again  getting these minutes without harden and  a foul on middleton  that's the third foul on middleton  [Applause]  but more importantly the nets of  shooting free throws it's just  reckless basketball be physical but be  smart  second down the last two minutes  [Applause]  oh durant from the line three for four  [Applause]  scan for your shot to win tickets to the  nba playoffs as well as other amazing  prizes michelob ultra courtside  it's only worth it if you enjoy it  fans courtside fans everywhere 16  000 plus here if i serve forum hoping to  get their bucks back  into the series after those two  disappointing performances  in brooklyn to fall 0-2  [Applause]  this is only the eighth free-throw  attempt  and that's only the 24th free-throw  attempt of the series for brooklyn